- C'est une bonne nouvelle,
vous diront les économistes.
L'augmentation de l'indice
des prix à la constitition, qui
a atteint un sommet en juin avec
une hausse de 8,1 %, a reculé
en juillet, se situant à 7,6 %.
Une différence qui s'explique
surtout avn n n ralentissement
de la croissance des prix
de l'essence.
BENOIT DUROCHER, économiste
principal, Mouvement Desjardins.
- aiaiait le facteur qui était
le plus plus facilement
observable par monsieur
et madame Tout-le-Monde
parce qu'évidemment,
on le constate chaque fois
qu'on croise une station
d'essence à un coin de rue.
- Le prix à la pompe
reste toutmmmême élevé
pour certains consommateurs.
- C'est trop cher,
c'est vraiment très cher,
surtout si quelqu'un travaille
comme... les livraisons de Uber.
Gagner la moitié, je paye
la moitié pour l'essence;
la moitié pour...
ça reste pour moi.
- La consommation de l'essence,
oui, dans le sens qu'on fait
attention jusqu'où on va
et on faits s s attention.
- La baisse du prix de l'essence
fait du bien au portefeuille,
tandis que le coût du panier
d'épicerie, une autre composante
du cl l l de l'IPC, reste élevé.
Certains aliments ont enregistré
une croissance accélérée, tels
que les oeufs, les fruits frais,
ainsi que le café et le thé.CoC:
il faut jongler avec
ce que l'on peut s'offrir.
- Je dépense moins parce que
j'achète des choses moins...
Je me donne pas de...
quelque chose ononon.
J'ai envie de biscuits
ou quelque chose,
j'ai arrêté tout ça.
- La faç'a'a'acheter les choses,
il faut réfléchir un peu plus.
Pour s'amuser aussi, pour
aller faire une activité,
il faut appeler avant pour
savoir combien ça va coûter.
- Pour les mois à venir,
les économistes prévoient
un ralentissmeent de
l'inflation, ce qui apportera
un peu plus de prévisibilité
pour les chaînes alimentaires,
et on pourrait même revoir
certains rabais sur les rayons,
sauf pour deux grandes
catégories d'aliments.
SYLVAIN CHARLEBOIS, sciences
agroalimentaire Univ. Dalhousie
- Les prix alimentaires
risq d d d'augmenter,
surtout pour deux catégories :
principalement la boulangerie
et les produits laitiers.
- La Commission canadienne
du lait a déjà indiquéununune he
à venir pour le 1er septembre.
Ici Carla Oliveira,
Radio-Canada, Montréa